Kevin McCarthy of the State of
California has received 216.
after four days 15 votes and a week
filled with quarreling and Chaos
Congress has elected its new house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy had to flip more
than a dozen conservatives to get the
votes he needed if there's one thing I
want the country to hopefully learned
about me this week is that I will never
give up Americans haven't seen such
disarray in this proceeding in over a
hundred years at one point tensions were
so high a fight almost broke out between
GOP lawmakers Mike Rogers and Matt Gates
who led the battle against McCarthy
McCarthy was forced to broker a deal
which weakens his own power allowing a
single member to call a vote to oust him
from Office Democrats say McCarthy
promised way too much to extremist
Republicans prompting this tongue
lashing from the House minority leader
on what his party wants reason over
racism substance over slander triumph
over tyranny understanding over ugliness
to get the votes he needed McCarthy
agreed to give conservatives more power
on house committees including one to
investigate the quote weaponization of
the federal government as Donald Trump
calls his ongoing investigations by the
FBI and Department of Justice McCarthy
gained the speakership and made it clear
who helped him to Victory I do want to
especially thank president Trump
I don't think you should anybody should
doubt his influence
he was with me from the beginning the
ultra conservatives also want more
investigations into President Joe Biden
his son Hunter greater border security
abortions restrictions cuts to some
federal employees salaries and possibly
Social Security and Medicare they told
the American people they wanted to win
the majority to fight inflation the only
thing they're fighting is each other
this kind of fighting and a divided
congress with Democrats still
controlling the Senate has Global
Watchers on high alert with everything
from Ukraine war funds to trade with
Canada America's closest Ally at risk
House Republicans are promising Unity
but Democrats and the president have
their doubts Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington